friendship friendship it's a Perfect
Blend chip I cannot believe she just got
me to do that yep
hi I'm Cheryl Lee Ralph and I'm Lisa Ann
Walter and we are spilling the E.T
the alarm twist never hurt
this is so exciting how much do you
enjoy working with me I love working
with you I'm your favorite right
yes you are absolutely you're very
spontaneous you're spunky and you listen
to the things that I tell you so that's
very good that bodes well for you it's
true what was your very first thought of
me I thought this could be a friend for
life oh
I think from the first time we sat at
the at our spots at the in the teacher's
lounge did you shake someone down for me
I shook someone down for us you bigger
boots
besides the chemistry which is just
legit I like that when we are in a scene
I'll just be like okay I'm gonna do I'm
gonna lean over this like that you know
give me a little push and she's like
okay and then she does that or she'll
say to me you know like just you know
come in hard you know or tell me by the
way you have my Barbara Howard voice I
have to yeah
it's iconic well thank you you're
welcome
knowing there's not much you can do Ava
be like Miss Howard people people always
mistake me for you're not used to seeing
your hair down yeah I guess you're right
that short hair oh my god when Quinta
said to me Miss Ralph you do not look
your age but hair and makeup will make
sure you do and they just make sure I do
it's like seeing your teacher outside of
school you got the teacher with a 27
piece wig right the famous wig and then
you go out those are called clip-ins and
on a good day they are tape ins oh I'm
sorry let me just sip more tea thank you
I did spill it
but they're not used to if they see you
somebody looking like you outside of the
pearls and the cashmere sweater oh my
gosh
I do love that it's Hot for Teacher oh
my God
we are only here to show face so that
people remember they saw us then we kick
it into Spa mode on tonight's episode
The Abba teachers go away on an
educational conference oh God it's one
of my favorite apps you know when it
comes to Janine when it comes to Janine
and Gregory yeah
when they kiss finally what when's that
happening I don't know when but when it
does happen I want it to last forever
sip tea and spill it to that part
the comedy about teachers in an inner
city school has racked up 36 trophies
including three prime time Emmys and
this Sunday the cast of Abbott
Elementary could take home two more
Awards including best TV comedy Ensemble
we've been nominated now for a Screen
Actors Guild Ensemble how do you feel
about the nomination I
picked out a dress at this gown place
downtown yeah
six years ago I was entirely unemployed
yeah I was mostly taking care of my mom
and I said I'm going to be at the SAG
Awards I'm going to wear this gown it is
it still work six years later oh honey I
look like a million bucks all in
twenties Brad Pitt might also be at the
SAG Awards with his he was a big top of
conversation amongst our cast of The
Golden Globe awards hey Brad Pitt
um
pull it together where you headed next
where am I to the after party today
after to rub shoulders with Brad Pitt
and I'm like what are you doing outside
Brad Pitt you should be in a famous man
uh location if you get a chance what is
your pitch to convince him to make a
cameo on Abbott you know something I
have to tell you this right now as much
as I appreciate Brad Pitt who I have met
before I say I do not get behind any of
this saying who should be on the show
because I believe that our writer's room
and our producer
our producers have done such an
excellent job of choosing our guest cast
that I am not going to say I don't know
that somebody as pretty as Brad Pitt
shows up at Abbott Elementary unless
he's playing Brad Pitt
it'd be more it would be more realistic
if it was Bradley Cooper who's from
Philly I would buy a Bradley Cooper
showing up at Abbott Elementary playing
my boyfriend oh Lord have mercy I'm such
a fan of a lot of the people that we run
into Hannah waddingham
I adore her on Ted lasso and she's
weirdly also SEPTA the nun on Game of
Thrones James okay so she said you know
what what would I be on Abbott
Elementary I I could be an annoying
English teacher what I loved about
meeting Hannah at the Emmys was
Hannah wears sneakers I mean do you not
love that she's my sister from another
man and mother yes and you're both tall
in your musical theater people Hannah
you better sip tea and spill it too
because on that one thank you did
someone call nine fun fun you didn't I
did after sad they're gonna be lots of
parties who parties the hardest in our
cast yes wouldn't it be fun if I said um
Stan Mr Johnson ah I'm gonna say that
back in the day he was party he was the
party hard monster there's a reason why
your voice gets like this right make
your voice deeper Tyler doesn't party
Janelle doesn't party Chris is the
biggest part here Christopher
Betty is the party he is the partier
that's that boy goes out I think you are
absolutely right about that yeah because
he comes in it's just that he's young
and he can hide the hangover uh but I
don't know if he drinks does he drink oh
okay anyway you did what I'm gonna sip
on that because you just spilled some
tea okay I want to ask you this question
tell me a secret that you have never
told anybody come on be brave
be brave
I'm gonna sip on that while you spill it
[Music]
am I gonna tell America this come on
tell me it's been a long time since I've
had a boyfriend right yes I had a
boyfriend for two years oh really yeah
we never had sex girl I know and you
couldn't tell that that was not the
right one to be with let me sip on that
because she did spill that thank you I
told you a secret what's the secret I
long to be a superhero
in our cast who is most like their
character and who is least like their
character there is the essence of every
one of our characters in each one of us
yeah but who's the most unlike their
character I would not be wearing those
pearls all the time as I clutch mine I
would agree that you were the least like
externally yes and you are not as
buttoned up as Barbara Howard thank you
I think that in in the show
Melissa loves saying things that might
shock Barbara Howard I think in real
life I feel safe and comfortable saying
anything to you although occasionally
I'd like to shock you get the cameras
out of my face before I give you a
colonoscopy with it for Melissa shimenti
what do you look forward for her
in the coming yeah we Zoom forward too
there are people that Melissa hasn't got
to have real big scenes with Ava which I
would love to see because they're both
such strong women honestly on this show
we have four Alpha females if you think
about it it's really wonderful too it is
because usually that's not the case in
television writing times have changed so
much now look at the fact that we are
the age that we are in an industry where
it used to be you couldn't be this and
think that you'd have an amazing career
and both of us are in the greatest
hottest number one show in the world in
the greatest characters ever
inspiring and making people laugh all
over the place and it's because we have
lasted to get to this time hell yeah we
have sipping tea and high five in you at
the same time on that as I drop my cards
I say we have spilled the tea
[Music]